all right the right hand side i haven't
done anything to it but i do need to
rewrite it because
i'm one step away from doing this
comparison of the real and imaginary
bits that we were talking about before
okay see this
see this here i actually have a
definition for that
right this guy here i defined it on our
very first line right here remember that
i still don't know what a and b are but
i can at least put them in place
because then i can do a comparison of
real and imaginary parts so let's go
ahead and do that
i've got this eye hanging out the front
some of you the gears are turning which
i'm glad for okay
let's just do the substitution okay so
i'm going to put in
a of x plus i b of x whatever those
happen to be
a of x plus i b
of x there we go there's the left hand
side here comes the right hand side
a dash plus i b dash
okay now thankfully i can like oh
great arithmetic i could do this i'm
multiplying some stuff by
i aren't i right and this is where i can
start to see which is the real part and
which is the imaginary part
hopefully you can see if i uh highlight
it here right
the real part is going to come from
these two together does that make sense
you've got an i at the front whoopsie
daisy and you've got the i that's
already attached to this b of x
so i times i by definition
minus one very good so you've got minus
b of x that's the real part
yeah you're with me and then the
imaginary part just comes from
the other bit right i times that so it's
i
times a of x one more time for good
measure i'll write this
okay we finally have real and imaginary
on the left
real imaginary on the right so now i'm
ready to do
my comparison let's see the real bits
first real
real yeah let's just jot that down uh
i'll keep it in red actually
um from the real comparison i get
that there's there's some function a
dash
that if i differentiate it you get minus
b
and then i've look at the imaginary part
uh wrong color sorry
i think this is the one that i have here
it is
and here it is can you tell me what what
are the bits that i'm going to write
together when i say
the imaginary part what's equal to what
yeah okay so b dash of x i mean you
could write it from either side really
but
that's going to be equal to a x cool
now remember my my goal i introduced
this notation this weird notation
a of x b of x because i didn't know what
they were right in some ways this is a
little bit like what we did at the
like in year 7 or a bit earlier with
algebra you're like oh there's some
number i don't know what it is
i'm just going to give it a name call it
x call it n and then i can start to do
stuff with it even when you don't know
what it is
you can still manipulate it okay and
that's exactly what we've done with this
notation there's some function
don't know what it is but i can
manipulate it
this is my endpoint and this is where we
just need to think
and have this beside oh conveniently
these graphs that we're just having a
look at here right
we're trying to think of two functions a
and b two functions a and b
uh i'm actually gonna start here when
you differentiate one function
you get to the other but then if you
differentiate this guy
you you come back to the original
function but with a minus sign
right now this is kind of weird because
well
we thought about i'll write it down
again we thought about things like this
right
x squared plus one to the power of five
okay now if you did have a death wish
and you expanded this thing out
you would have a polynomial where the
biggest power would be what
have a look at it it'd be ten wouldn't
it be except have ten and then speed
some expert have nines
eight seven et cetera right now when you
differentiate it when you differentiate
it
you end up with something and its
biggest power is not ten it's
nine and if you did it again you'd get
something with the biggest power of
eight and then seven and so on right so
in order in other words when you keep on
differentiating the powers go down down
down down down
this can't be that right because you
differentiate one
then you differentiate again you kind of
come back to where you started
so there's kind of like this loop
happening right now remembering that
derivatives are about gradient i now
want you to look
stare really hard at those three graphs
i asked you to do
at the start let's look at sine x here's
sine x
okay what can you tell me about it's
gradient
well it starts off positive doesn't it
starts a positive
at this point here right that's all
that's pi on two right at this point
here
what can you tell me about the gradient
of sine x
it's zero isn't it because it stops
being positive it's about to be negative
but at this point it's zero and then for
like this middle portion
it's negative y goes down the slide
right and then the final portion here
the gradient comes back to being
positive yeah
positive zero negative
zero again positive doesn't that sound
and look a whole lot like cosine
do you see that here's cosine is
positive then it's negative
then it's positive again so if you
differentiate sine and we can actually
prove this rigorously rather than just
look at a picture
i told you this was an informal proof
right when you differentiate sine you
end up in cosine what happens when you
differentiate again here's cosine right
well this part's negative isn't it like
do you see it sliding down i'm thinking
about gradient now right
it's great it's negative it's negative
is negative at this point here
gradient zero it's flat again and then
positive positive positive positive
doesn't this look familiar too doesn't
this look exactly
like negative sign do you see that you
see what's happening
this guy's negative just like this
gradient is negative
this part is positive just like this
gradient is positive
are you with me so therefore we can
actually say
the only two functions that we know that
will actually
fit this the characteristics that we
want
is that b of x this has to be
sine of x right because when you
differentiate this guy
right you will get to a which
we've just determined should be cos
right i don't know why i drew these
brackets here
right but then when you differentiate
cos again you don't come back exactly to
sign you come back to the
upside down version of sine do you see
that
so sine and cosine are the mystery a and
b
that i was after so can we tie this all
up in a neat bow
right i don't need these graphs at last
they have served their purpose
i'm going to go back to that very
original line
and i'm going to say well if e to the i
x
this guy here equals this function a
plus an imaginary this function b
i'm just going to put in the a and b i
just worked out
and it should look creepily familiar
this is what we get
this equation here put a big box around
it and i want you to give it
a name this equation here is called
euler's formula
we're going to do a lot of work with
euler's formula as you can see it's a
really
important result because it connects
some really
weird ideas right but most importantly
for us today
i want to make sure that you connect
this with what we already know
right see this right hand side cos x
plus i sine x
we're clearly in complex number land
right because there's an i here but we
don't usually write this guy on the
right hand side
in this form we're used to thinking of
this thing here
that goes into cos and goes into sine we
would call that the
starts with an a it's the what of the
complex number
it's the argument isn't it so to sort of
remind us that it's an angle
we usually write it as a theta do you
remember that right this is how we
introduced
polar form well if i've changed these
x's into thetas
then i guess i should change this x also
into a theta is that okay that make
sense
but then last step
this is this is good uh you know the
argument any argument that i like i can
put into here
but complex numbers don't just have an
argument that tells you where the
complex number is what's the second
piece that you need to know
you need to know a modulus right and ah
so
that's actually really easy to fix i
just have to take this whole thing
multiply both sides by ah that modulus
so
i don't even need to change my line i'm
going to just put it in a different
color
like so if i multiply both left and
right hand side by r
i'm going to put it here there's the
right hand side
and then here is the left hand side
take a breath what have we just done
what have you done um we started off
thinking about complex numbers as
um you just put together a real and
imaginary bit and then
we sort of went into we went to trig
territory right polar form
we've got a rectangular form we've got a
polar form
but now we also have
one third and final form i'm like
my boys this is really weird because i
was like this almost when i was their
age but my boys are really into pokemon
so if you want to think about like the
evolution
of like some i don't know like it's look
at my squirtle he's turned into a
blastoise okay
this is what we call not rectangular
form not polar form
what do you think would be a reasonable
name for this
exponential form and this guy here i
know we were talking
um a couple of lessons back about like
oh man
i hate writing r cos the inter plus i
sign theta it takes forever it's so long
can we abbreviate in this some way right
and i said to you just wait if you would
like a succinct way to write a complex
number
this is it okay so
we are going to spend some time um
exploring
what this thing can do and what it's
good at um and you'll be relieved um
having introduced
st sorry rectangular polar and
exponential form
there are no more forms we're not going
to pull like a rather out of hands like
there's a there's a fifth and a sixth
and
there are three forms of complex numbers
this is the last one in many ways it's
kind of the coolest but we'll get to
that later